let's go to our next caller from the
two-month [ __ ] area code caller from
to14 who's this where you calling from
what's on your mind hello can you hear
me yes we can who's this my name is Kyle
I'm calling from Tuscaloosa Alabama
great but I'm originally from Dallas
Texas
oh all right well that's okay um so my
question is about the recent bombs
discovered at the addresses of prominent
democratic political influencers I guess
included mr. Soros and the media
response to this and my question is why
is the media calling these things
suspicious packages or bomb scares
instead of assassination attempts and
right-wing terrorism well there are a
few answers to that question number one
a lot of the early reporting airs on the
side of caution so sometimes you have
something that might literally at that
point not have been confirmed to be an
actual bomb right so number one if
they're not sure that it's an actual
bomb then maybe they would err on the
side of caution this isn't a defense by
the way Kyle I'm just sort of telling
you where I see it right-wing terror
they're not going to call it and we all
know why because immediately they would
be targeted by the right for being
biased liberal media and all of those
other further ad homonyms that are used
and the truth is that corporate media is
very afraid of being branded in that way
because it's not good for them that's
the reality there is a right-wing
machine that has been calling basically
everything about Fox News and right-wing
radio liberal media for more than a
decade at this point and it has an
impact and I know from speaking to
people in corporate media that they go
out of their way to avoid coverage that
makes it easier for them to be branded
in that way so the idea of saying
right-wing terror I mean it's just
they're not going to do it
and I I started it kind of ironic
because you hear these people talking
about what they like Trump because he's
not politically correct and because
tells it like it is but then when you
start calling them out and using what it
is they get defensive and retreat to
their safe spaces a lot they do and then
the other one also is that they say it's
a false flag right that's the other kind
of one that they will resort to which is
when it becomes completely undeniable
and you do start getting honest
reporting from media saying these were
people motivated by right-wing ideas
these were people motivated by antipathy
towards left-wing ideas or left-wing
people then you start to sow seeds of
doubt by saying isn't it too perfect
that it was all liberals who got the
suspicious packages or bombs or whatever
they were it clearly was staged to
create a pretext to criticize the right
so this is where I get back to Kyle it
we have to just forget about what they
think because they're not honest actors
they're not good faith participants in
figuring out the future of our country
and of humanity and we need to get
around them and and try to do what we
can to improve circumstances without
their participation because they'll
either say that it's it's liberally
biased or it's fake or you're not
hearing the other side of the story or
whatever they're not going to be part of
the solution no matter what that
solution is oh well thank you probably
like all oh my pleasure thank you so
much for calling yeah that's uh if
you're waiting around for a corporate
media to say right-wing terror explodes
under Trump you'll have some guests say
it sometimes you will have people who
come on and say listen the overwhelming
majority of the violence is is from the
from the right but as far as a corporate
media headline saying that's our
position you're not really gonna see
that not in line with the neutrality
bias that they have it is not certainly